le 14 mars la ligne sncf entre la
verrière et la défense devrait reprendre
du service
la ligne est totalement interrompu
depuis une semaine en cause l'incendié
d'un poste de signalisation à sèvres en
incendie a détruit l'ensemble du système
de commande et des signalisations sur la
ville d'avray
c'est ce système qui permet
aux lignes u et l2 d'accéder sur 5 nous
le système de signalisation et de
commandes il détecte l'arrivée des
trains il permet aussi de réguler et là
ça fait 100 des trains une ligne
interrompus ce sont cinquante mille
voyageurs quotidiens qui doivent trouver
des itinéraires de délestage
dès lundi une centaine d'agents en gilet
rouge étaient mobilisés dans les gares
pour renseigner des annonces sonores
diffusés très régulièrement et la sncf a
aussi mis l'accent sur les nouvelles
technologies
on a communiqué au niveau du blog de la
ligne n et u et sur twitter également
donc des nouvelles technologies qui
commencent à se dépeupler de plus en
plus pour communiquer sur sur un
syndiqué lieu sûr dans le poste de
signer vision de sèvres équipe qui du
coup un impact et la circulation des
trains est interrompue complètement la
circulation des trains retour donc à la
normale prévue dans une dizaine de jours
le système de signalisation vieux de 20
ans sera changé les agents de la sncf
s'activent à tout remettre en route
rapidement car quand une ligne est au
ralenti l'entreprise doit verser des
pénalités ou stif le syndicat des
transports d'île de france et elles
pourraient s'élever jusqu'à 3 millions
d'euros
quant aux voyageurs pas de dédommagement
particulier ils ont reçu des coupons de
dépannage leur permettant de rejoindre
gratuitement paris pour les
correspondances